it's a brand new school year for
students across the valley thank you for
joining us at noon i'm bianca holman
so today clark county school district
welcomed over 310
000 kids back to the classroom after
more than a year of distance learning
and hybrid schedules
hector mejia live from matt kelly
elementary school where some students
greeted with the red carpet arrival
hi hector yeah hey there and besides the
red carpet welcome
every student here at matt kelly
elementary school also received
a free backpack it's a title one school
and i'm told
students here face additional challenges
as we jump into this new school year
and here alone here alone at this campus
roughly about 290 students
and 30 teachers returned to matt kelly
elementary
and they were greeted by superintendent
dr jesus jarrah
governor steve sisilak and other elected
officials with music
cheering and a gift for this campus
located in the historic
west side has been around since the
1960s
every student got a free backpack with a
meal kit inside
as the title one school the principal
says some of their students face food
insecurity
we've also learned that some families
are still recovering from pandemic
layoffs
some of our kids haven't been on campus
in 18 months so we're really wanting to
make sure that we're taking care of
their emotional needs
like so excited i really ran out of my
bed
i got a kindergarten second grade fourth
grade and fifth grader
i'm excited for them i think that last
year they didn't get a full
year of being here and it really
affected them so i think it's a good
thing for them to come back
a lot of excitement in the air today and
some school you know all schools trying
to start things as normal as possible
however masks are required indoors and
while on school buses at ccsd
the district is starting off though with
over 700 teacher vacancies and about 200
bus drivers short in the meantime school
employees who have the appropriate
driver's license are taking some of the
bus routes and we're told
the district is asking parents to have
some patience there may be some delays
as drivers are getting used to the bus
routes and they're also reminding
parents
to be careful around crosswalks and
school zones now that kids
are back in the classroom reporting near
j street and lake mead boulevard hector
mejia
8 news now